CONTINUING TO GAIN MORE MOMENTUM
AS MORE AND MORE IS LEARNED
ABOUT BARNES.
AND SENATOR JOHNSON JOINS US
NOW.
SENATOR, GREAT TO SEE YOU.
LET'S SEE.
HE WANTS TO DEFUND THE POLICE.
HE WANTS TO OPEN UP THE PRISONS.
HE BELIEVES THAT ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS SHOULD GET INSTATE
TUITION AND DRIVER'S LICENSES
OPINION SUPPORTS EVERY PART OF
THE SOCIALIST GREEN NEW DEAL,
EVEN WAS PART OF THE RADICAL
WORKING FAMILIES PARTY.
HE WANTS TO GET RID OF THE
LEGISLATIVE FILL BUSKER, NO
RESTRICTIONS ON ABORTION.
LEGALIZE MARIJUANA.
HE LOGGED MORE THAN TEN TILES AS
MANY -- TIMES AS MANY HOURS FOR
PERSONAL SECURITY.
AND OF COURSE, THE STEVE SCALISE
COMMENTS.
I THINK YOU'RE A LUCKY MAN,
SENATOR, BECAUSE YOU EXPOSING
THAT RECORD MEANS YOU WILL WIN
THE STATE OF WISCONSIN.
>> WELL, SEAN, YOU'RE RIGHT.
HE'S A RADICAL LEFTIST, BUT HE'S
HIDING IN SHEEP'S CLOTHING.
OF COURSE, HE'S GOT THE MEDIA
THAT AMPLIFYING THE LIES HE'S
TELLING ABOUT ME.
BUT YOU MENTION THE SECURITY
THAT HE VIEWS THE STATE PATROL.
OVER $600,000.
13.5 HOURS A DAY, SEVEN DAYS A
WEEK, 365 DAYS A YEAR.
THIS IS SOMEBODY WHO WANTS TO
DEFUND POLICE.
HE'S HOSTILE TO LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND YET HE'S HAPPY TO USE THEM
AS HIS PERSONAL CHAUFFEUR
SERVICE ALL AROUND THE STATE.
AND OUT OF STATE AS WELL.
SO HE'S A HYPOCRITE.
HE'S A RADICAL LEFTIST.
HE NEEDS TO BE DEFETED BUT I'M
GOING TO ANYING THE RESOURCES.
RONJOHNSONFORSENATE.COM.
>> OBVIOUSLY, THAT'S THE CASE.
ARE PEOPLE OF WISCONSIN FULLY
AWARE OF THAT RECORD THAT I JUST
OUTLINED?
IN OTHER WORDS, DO THEY KNOW IT?
ARE THEY BEING TOLD?
IS IT COMING OUT?
WILL YOU HAVE DEBATES WITH HIM?
>> I THINK THERE HAS BEEN A
SHIFT IN THE POLLS BECAUSE TRUTH
IS GETTING OUT.
HE'S PRETTY GOOD AT HIDING.
WE'RE SMOKING THE MOUNTAIN.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A DEBATE ON
FRIDAY AND ANOTHER ONE ON
THURSDAY.
HE'S STARTING TO BE INTERVIEWED,
BUT, YOU KNOW, SEAN I'VE DONE
HUNDREDS -- MORE THAN 100
INTERVIEWS SINCE HE WAS A --
BECAME THE NOMINEE.
HE HAD DONE UNTIL RECENTLY ABOUT
FOUR.
HE'S IN HIDING.
HE DOESN'T WANT WISCONSINIANS TO
KNOW WHO HE IS.
THE ADS HE'S RUNNING, HE'S
BUYING MILK.
HE'S MAKING A PEANUT BUTTER
SANDWICH.
HE DOESN'T TALK ABOUT HIS
HOSTILITY ABOUT LAW ENFORCEMENT.
HE DOESN'T TALK ABOUT THE FACT
THAT HE SAID THE -- THAT HE
IMPLIES THAT OUR -- HE WON'T AND
THE NEWS MEDIA HERE IN WISCONSIN
WON'T TELL WISCONSINIANS TRUTH.
THAT'S WHY I NEED HELP FROM YOUR
VIEWERS RONJOHNSONFORSENATE.COM
SO WE CAN GET THE TRUTH OUT SO
HE DOES NOT SERVE THE U.S.
SENATE.
>> SENATOR, THIS RACE IS A MUST
HOLD REPUBLICANS ARE TO HAVE ANY
CHANCE OF WINNING BACK THE
SENATE AND HAVING CONTROL, WHICH
IS CRITICAL.